miss ocasio-cortez
thank you mr chair uh mr cohen i'd like
to quickly
pick up on some previous lines of
questioning before getting into my own
so i may go a little quickly and to get
it all in five minutes
uh first my colleague from vermont had
asked you
several questions about ami the parent
company of the national enquirer
and uh in that you mentioned a treasure
trove a quote treasure trove of
documents
in david pecker's office relating to
information assembled from all these
catch and kill
operations against people who
potentially had damaging information on
the president
you also mentioned that the president
was very concerned about the whereabouts
of these documents and who possessed
them does that treasure trove of
documents still exist
i i don't know i had asked david pecker
for them
so you would say the person who knows
the whereabouts of these documents would
be david pecker
david pecker barry levine or
dylan howard okay thank you um secondly
i want to ask a little bit
about uh your conversation with my
colleague from missouri about
acid inflation um to your knowledge did
the president ever provide inflated
assets to an insurance company
yes who else knows that the president
did this
allen weisselberg ron lieberman and
matthew calamari
and where would the committee find more
information on this do you think we need
to review his financial statements and
his tax returns in order to compare them
yes and you'd find it at the trump org
thank you very much
uh the last last thing here the trump
golf organization
currently has a golf course in my home
borough
of the bronx uh trump lynx i drive past
it
every day going between bronx and going
between the bronx and queens
in fact the washington post reported on
the trump links bronx course in an
article entitled
taxpayers built this new york golf
course and trump reaps the rewards
were many that that article is where
many new yorkers and people in the
country learn that taxpayers spent 127
million dollars
to build trump links in a quote generous
deal
allowing president trump to keep almost
every dollar
that flows in on a golf course built
with public funds
and this doesn't seem to be the only
time the president has benefited at the
expense of the public
mr cohen i want to ask you about your
assertion that the president may have
improperly devalued his assets to avoid
paying taxes
according to an august 24 to august 21
2016 report by the washington post
while the president claimed in financial
disclosure forms that trump national
golf club in jupiter florida
was worth more than 50 million he had
reported
otherwise to local tax authorities that
the course was worth quote
no more than 5 million mr cohen do you
know whether this specific report is
accurate
it's identical to what he did at trump
national golf club
at briarcliff manor do you know to your
knowledge was the president interested
in reducing his local real estate bills
tax bills yes and how did he do that
what you do is you deflate the value of
the asset and then you
put in a request to the tax department
for a deduction thank you now in october
2018 the new york times revealed that
quote
president trump participated in dubious
tax schemes during the 1990s including
instances
of outright fraud that greatly increased
the fortune he received
from his parents and it further stated
from mr trump quote
he also helped formulate a strategy to
undervalue his parents real estate
holdings
by hundreds of millions of dollars on
tax returns
sharply reducing his tax bill when those
properties were transferred to him
and his siblings mr cohen do you know
whether that specific report is accurate
i i don't i wasn't there in 1990s
who would know the answer to those
questions allen weisselberg
and would it help for the committee to
obtain federal and state tax returns
from the president and his company to
address that
discrepancy i believe so thank you very
much i yield the rest of my time to the
chair